been sitting to read what all of you can
be faster than I can speak from a very
nice waiter Thank You Andre thank you
all for coming I'd like to thank the
organizers for this invitation is this
mic level okay okay all right I'm going
to tell you about a project today that
I'm working on with Danny Caligari and
Alden Walker it's a project that we're
about to wrap up but there are still
many questions that you would like to
answer and some kind of neat things that
we don't completely understand yet this
is a project in dynamics and geometry
but before I tell you about the
particulars of that project I'm going to
start with a discussion of what happens
for the quadratic family of polynomial Z
maps to Z squared plus C in the realm of
complex dynamics and then I'll tell you
specifically about we're doing which has
some sort of surprising applications to
polynomials algebra and is in fact
related sort of mysteriously to two
other dynamical systems and dynamical
quantities that have been recently
studied okay so we'll start with the
preliminary discussion of the quadratic
family Z maps to Z squared plus C p sub
C here's this particular quadratic
polynomial mapping the complex plane to
itself whenever you have a polynomial
you can define a non-empty compact
invariant sets the subset of the complex
plane called the fill Julia set which by
definition consists of all points that
do not escape off to infinity under
iteration so the sequence of iterates is
bounded so here are some pictures of
what those sets might look like for the
quadratic family the parameters see here
this is a complex number when c equals 0
the fill Julia said is just the closed
unit disk when C equals minus 1 you get
this nice fractal here this is known in
some circles as the Basilica fractal
when C equals I you'll get this guy here
this is the dendrite the fill Julia set
has empty interior and when C equals
minus 2.5 you get this set here this is
a cantor set so this shows you just some
of the behavior that you can get as you
vary the parameter C
and study the dynamical set in the
complex plane I want to point out that
every single one of these green pictures
has a distinguished point there's a
distinguished point in the dynamical
plane for each one of these guys the
sent the center of symmetry this is a
critical point the unique critical point
for the quadratic polynomial and it's
geometrically distinguished it's the
center of symmetry of the fill Julia set
and in fact it's dynamically
distinguished also i'll talk about that
in a second okay so for the quadratic
family there's a fundamental dichotomy
either the fill Julia sets is connected
or it is a cantor set and totally
disconnected so there are perhaps three
subsets of parameter space that might be
of interest to us so remember see here's
our complex parameter our parameter
space is a copy of the complex plane and
we might want to study three particular
subsets just to see what we can we can
say about how the shapes of these fill
Julia sets vary as you move the
parameter so the first set I'll call
script M by definition this will be the
set of all parameters C for which the
fill Julia set is connected the set
script M prime will be the set of all
parameters C for which 0 the critical
point or the center of symmetry of these
sets is inside the fill Julia set and
then the set M double prime which
consists of all parameters C for which
the dynamical set is both connected and
full so in this talk I'll use the word
full to mean a subset of the complex
plane whose complement is connected okay
so a set that's full has no holes in it
all right so you might want to study
each one of these sets in turn and in
fact it turns out that they coincide for
this particular family so the set drawn
in black here is the Mandelbrot sets
this is parameter space our C parameter
plane for Z maps to Z squared plus C the
set em as I said is the Mandelbrot set
and by definition it consists of all
parameters C for which the field Julius
that is connected it is the
connectedness locus for this family the
set M is in fact equal to the set
Prime this results is just a standard
complex dynamics result it goes all the
way back to times of Fatu that the Phil
Julia said is connected if and only if
it contains the critical point or the
center of symmetry so those two sets
coincide and in fact the reason these
sets are called filled Julia sets is
because they are in fact always full so
if it's connected it will be full so the
set M double prime coincides with a set
em all so that's a maximum modulus
argument to tell you that these things
are all full they have no holes in them
so all three of these sets are the same
and they're equal to this set here so we
can ask about certain features of the
Mandelbrot set this has been very well
studied it's sort of a central object of
interest and then is in a strong sense
Universal in a way that you can make
precise here's some facts about it it is
compact it is connected this is a
theorem of duty and Hubbard and in fact
it follows from their arguments that the
Mandelbrot set is also full as a subset
of the complex plane so the Mandelbrot
set doesn't have any holes in it either
ok it is equal to the closure of its
interior now we don't yet know what all
of the interior of the Mandelbrot set
looks like but we do in fact know that
if you take the topological closure of
the set of interior points you'll get
the Mandelbrot set back and it is
unknown whether or not this set is
locally connected Jeremy gave us an
update on this problem last night this
is something he's working on ok I do
want to make a couple remarks among the
components of the Interior are the so
called hyperbolic components these are
components of the Interior where the
critical point is attracted to an
attracting cycle and as you move through
this component in parameter space the
dynamics change is very predictably so
as you move across one hyperbolic
component you'll always have an
attracting cycle of a certain period and
the Julia sets will in some sense have
the same shape will move continuously
and this picture is extremely well
organized with respect to those
hyperbolic components so here's the big
central component here this is a
hyperbolic component that contains the
parameter zero here's a hyperbolic
component interior of this come
ponent which contains the parameter
minus one and so on every hyperbolic
component has a unique center where the
critical point is periodic and in fact
you can extract some finite
combinatorial data to label these
hyperbolic components in parameter space
and build a road map that helps you
navigate your way through this set and
then you can really understand much of
the combinatorial structure of this set
with the hyperbolic components now as I
said we don't know that every component
of the interior is hyperbolic that's
closely related to this question here
okay but the point is those components
are nice and you can use finite data to
tell them apart and to navigate your way
through this set and just one remark
about how the Julia set Smoove as you
move in parameter space as soon as you
cross the boundary of the Mandelbrot set
that Julia sets will move
discontinuously in the house Dorf metric
ok so that's it for a quadratic
polynomial warm-up let's keep this in
mind and i'll tell you about the
particular family that Danny Eldon and I
are studying so we're studying a little
bit more of a generalized dynamical
system we're studying iterated function
systems so most generally if an iterated
function system is the following object
X is a complete metric space and we'll
take a finite set of contractions
mapping X to itself and it's not so hard
to see by using essentially the same
argument that proves the contraction
mapping fixed point theorem that there's
a non-empty compact a tractor in the
dynamical plane that you can get by
taking just a generic point and mapping
it forward under different maps in your
generating sets accumulation set of the
forward orbit of that point will be this
attractor ok that's called lambda and it
has the property that it's equal to the
union of its images under the generators
so in fact lambda looks like it has a
bunch of small copies of it inside
itself because all these maps are
contractions so here's an example you
can get the sierpinski gasket as a limit
set for an iterated function system with
three generators so what are the
generators well you just look at the
affine map of the plane
it takes this triangle to this triangle
that's one generator the map that takes
the big triangle to the top triangle and
the map that takes the big triangle to
this triangle over here there are your
three generators and this will be the
limit set for that iterated function
system okay so these things are made up
of small copies of themselves copies of
themselves at smaller scales okay so
I'll be studying a particular
parameterised family of iterated
function systems the family I will be
looking at will have two generators in
it they'll be acting on the complex
plane see here is a parameter these maps
are supposed to be contractions they're
just affine transformations or
similarities and so the scaling factor
should have modulus less than 1 okay to
be an ifs and each one of these maps has
a fixed point with respect to which it's
contracting just a fine similarities
transformations of the complex plane I'd
like to say that if you study another
parameterised family where the parameter
is the scaling factor and that family
consists of just is generated by just
two elements like this one then in fact
it's conjugate to one of this form so it
might look like I'm studying some very
special family but that's not the case
okay and the limits set here will be the
closure of the set of fixed points of
the element in the semi-group generated
by these these two all right so if you
wanted to draw this limit set what might
you do so the limit set is a compact
subset of C so you could take a large
disc which will contain it and then you
can map it forward under words of a
given length words in the generators so
for instance I could take the disc and
map it forward under words of length 1
that of course is just mapping it
forward under each of the generators and
so I my one disc will become 2 discs I
can look at those two discs and then map
those two discs forward under F and
under G and then I'll have four discs
and then eight disks and so on so I keep
mapping this one big disc forward lots
and lots of times and I can look at this
will be a nested set and I can take the
intersection over looking at words of
any length so working
of all the lengths and taking the nest
intersection it will limit down to the
limit set so i keep approximating it
with these disks now here's a picture of
what i mean so we start with a big disk
we look at it under F and under G the
blue disk is the image of the original
disk under F the orange disk is the
original the image of the original disk
under G we get this picture the limit
set is contained in these disks the
fixed point of one of the generators is
here the fixed point of the other is
here will map it forward again there are
four disks the limits set is going to be
contained in this union of four disks
will map that forward under F and under
G again and now we have eight and then
we have 16 and so on and so at the end
of the day we can approximate our limit
set with this recipe ok so throughout
this talk I'll be drawing my limit set
in two colors one will be blue and one
will be one will be orange so the blue
is the image of the whole limit set
under F and the orange is the limit of
the whole it is the image of the whole
limit set under G so you can see that
the limit set here you have a small copy
a small blue copy coming from F a small
orange copy coming from G and in fact if
you zoom in further each of these small
copies is made up of two small copies of
the limit set and so on so a word and F
and G will just give you a shrunken
limit set and what that word is gives
you the address of where that shrunken
limit said actually is in the big one
all right so if you want to certify with
a computer I have a computer picture and
I'd like to know something topological
about the limit set so if you want to
certify that this limit set is
disconnected that actually isn't too bad
so the limit set will be disconnected if
at some point in this approximation
procedure with these disks the blue
piece and the orange piece are disjoint
that will separate the limit set ok and
a computer can test that certifying that
it's connected is much harder talk about
that next all right so what do we know
about the topology so connectedness the
limit set is in fact connected if the
blue piece and the orange piece the
image under F and the image under G have
non empty intersection ok that's an if
and only if
and if the limit said is disconnected
this is related to my previous comment
then there is a topological disk which
contains it so that just one image under
F and one image under gr enough to
separate it okay so before we're taking
some large enough disk and mapping it
forward enough times to eventually
separate the blue and the orange this
statement is saying that there is in
fact one topological disk so if you look
at the image under F and G that will be
enough to separate it and just like with
the family of quadratic polynomials
there's a fundamental dichotomy the
limit set is either connected or it's a
cantor set okay so here are some
pictures of what it might look like this
is supposed to look like a cantor set
but the points are very close together
so it looks a little chunkier than it
should here it's connected connected
connected so just as before for
quadratic polynomials we can study some
subsets of parameter space but remember
my parameter space is now my scaling
factor space it's not no longer a copy
of the complex plane it's a copy of the
puncture disk so I can start to write
down some distinguished subsets of
parameter space to that end I'd like to
point out that just as with quadratic
polynomials there is a center of
symmetry for these these pictures just
like before so remember we're generating
this limit set by looking at two
iterated to a two generator iterated
function system each function is an
affine transformation and has a fixed
point the midpoint between the fixed
point of F and the fixed point of G will
be a center of symmetry for the limit
set you can see it in these pictures so
here it is here it's right there for
this one so this is playing a role of a
type of critical point ok so just as
before in the quadratic family of
polynomials we could write down the
definition of three subsets of parameter
space and ask well are they all the same
are they all different what do they look
like and then study those particular
subsets so there's our family up at the
top the set M is the set of all
parameters for which the limit set is
connected the connectedness locust again
the set M prime is the set of all
parameters for which the limit set
contains the critical point or the
center of symmetry and the set M double
prime is
set of all parameters for which the
limit set is connected and full so
remember the limits that is full if its
complement is connected okay so what
actually happens well each one of these
sets is a closed subset of the puncture
disk and in fact no two of them are
equal but you have this containment
relation so we can see that here let's
just go through some of these examples
for this particular parameter the limits
that is disconnected so it's not in any
of these sets so it's disconnected the
center of symmetry is not inside the
limit sets and it's disconnected so of
course the parameter the corresponding
parameter is not in the set M double
prime for this limit set here it is
connected the blue and the orange
intersect but the center of symmetry is
not inside the limit set so this picture
corresponds to a parameter which is an M
but not M Prime and also this parameter
is not an M double Prime either you can
see that it's not full over here we have
a limit set that is connected the center
of symmetry is inside but this thing
isn't full either so this parameter is
inside the set em and in the inside the
set M prime but not in the set M double
Prime and over here you have a limit set
where the blue and the orange intersect
in exactly one point in fact the center
of symmetry necessarily so the
corresponding parameter is in fact in
all three of these sets so you can use
some relatively simple arguments to
prove this containment relation okay
alright so what are these sets look like
now we know that they're all different
oh I should make her mark about
continuity so in contrast to the family
of quadratic polynomials as you vary the
parameter for this particular iterated
function system the limit sets move
continuously in the house tour metric
it's very different from what happens
for Z squared plus seat
okay so here are two pictures these were
drawn with this great computer program
which is available at this URL if you'd
like to explore and look at it in fact
I'll show it to you in a second so on
the left here is a picture of the
connectedness locus the set of all
parameters in our parameter space which
the limits that is connected on the
right is that set M Prime the set of
parameters for which the limit set
contains the center of symmetry and
based on what I said before the set on
the right is a subset a proper subset of
the set on the left sorry the color the
colored set good question yes the
colored set is this is the set that
you're looking at yes good question so
stergios asked me about the coloring so
these these sets are colored according
to how hard the computer had to work to
do something and i'll make more comments
about that in a second so just a couple
of remarks about the geometry of these
sets so you'll notice one thing they're
prominent spikes or whiskers that are
piercing this large great lake in the
center here so those actually really are
there there's an open subset this point
here is one half this point here is
minus one half there's an open subset of
the complex plane containing one half
that intersects the set em on my pointer
stein the set em the set em in just a
subset of the real numbers similarly
over here so those spikes have no
complex decorations on them thanks here
those spikes have no complex decorations
on them that's where the set is just a
subset of our ok moreover there's some
symmetry so each one of these sets is
symmetric with respect to reflection
across the real axis and with respect to
reflection across the imaginary axis so
in fact if you want to study these sets
it suffice is to just focus your
attention on one corner of the picture
you don't have to study the entire thing
ok so let me do some computer
experiments now just to show you some
thank you oh I should have set this up
earlier
here okay
ok
alright so this is this wonderful
program that we've been using to explore
this this this iterated function system
it was mostly written by alden walker
who's this great this great guy at
chicago on the left here is the
dynamical plane on the right here is
parameter space this is some
approximation to the set em so as i drag
my cursor around hopefully you can see
let's see here hopefully you can see how
the limits that changes on the left in
the dynamical plane so as I'm walking
through the white region you can see
that the the set is a cantor set and
then as I cross over into the colorful
regions that connects up the boundary
looks kind of interesting down here
where those spikes were I can refine
this picture of it down here where those
spikes were on the real axis the limit
set becomes an interval here's the point
one half where the blue and the orange
touch in just one point then if I move a
little to the left separates completely
and I get a cantor set back so we can
start to zoom into this picture let me
see here zoom into a point on the
boundary and then I'm refining how the
computer is drawing the connectedness
locus you can move around here okay and
let me see here okay there we go it
looks like something AHA there it is so
I'm here and i'll zoom in a little more
so there's the boundary it looks pretty
nice and fractal and one thing that we
were very surprised to find was this
let's zoom in a little more okay so what
is that
alright so in fact the computer has
found a hole inside the set em it's
found a component of the complement of
the connectedness locus that isn't that
large great lake in the center there's
the central component we're moving
around the parameter before looking at
the cantor set change and now we found a
hole inside em we found what i'll call
an exotic component of the compliment
and in fact if this thing is really
there there probably are infinitely many
of them in dynamics of course you don't
usually ever find one of something so if
you zoom in in various areas with this
program it's actually really neat you
can see these things that are arranged
in families which suggests some kind of
a normalization phenomenon and you can
try to study it and that's what our
project is about ok back to keynote
alright so here's another zoom in to em
and the chicken into the connectedness
locus the set m prime we could also
study but I'll focus my attention on em
for the time being so here some of those
holes I think this was the one that I
just showed you here are some baby ones
some smaller ones spiraling around it
here's a nice family this is the central
great lake component here's a nice
family of whole spiraling down to some
limit okay so what are these holes and
and why are they there are they there ok
so we are certainly not the first people
to have studied this particular family
or this this connectedness locus the
subset of parameter space as far as we
can tell this goes back to nineteen
eighty-five with Barnsley and Harrington
who proved this is the original picture
who proved that this set em really does
have those real whiskers so that there
are no complex decorations in a
neighborhood of one half okay in 1988
and 1993 Terry bouche wrote some papers
where he proved that the set em and in
fact the set M Prime are both connected
and locally connected which is kind of
interesting if you compare this to the
Mandelbrot set discussion
2002 Christoph bant actually found that
the set M is not full as a subset of the
open unit disk so he was the first one
to discover that these holes actually
existed he proved that there is at least
one exotic component of a compliment
there's his original picture and he
wondered about the interior of this set
and conjectured that the interior of
this set is in fact dense away from the
real axis we already know that the real
axis is going to be a problem because
the set is very thin there there are
those whiskers there's no way that the
interior is dense in the whole thing but
if you remove the real whiskers maybe
maybe you can say something and a lot of
people this list is certainly not
exhaustive but slow me I can jus and
slow Mac and some other people have
studied this from a topological point
also they prove that M has dense
interior in a neighborhood of the
imaginary axis okay so this is just a
small subset of the the literature that
exists about this particular family and
what I'm going to focus on is the set of
interior points so there are two results
I'd like to share with you the first is
that the interior of the connectedness
locus is in fact dense away from the
real axis so staying away from those
real whiskers where you know that you
have no interior points the interior is
dense and the second theorem is that
there are in fact infinitely many holes
in EM there are infinitely many exotic
components of the complement of this
thing figuring out what they mean and
how they're arranged is a really
interesting question and we don't
understand that yet okay
alright so let me just set us up with a
result of teary Boosh so he knew
something about the interior so back in
nineteen ninety eight Terry bouche
proved that the set em in fact contains
this annulus so this number is like
point seven which is right around here
ish so there's there's a solid annulus
here where there aren't any holes and
you have lots of interior sort of toward
the edge where the picture gets darker
the holes actually seem to exist closer
to the boundary outside of this region
here okay so we have this sort of
annular region around the outside where
we know there are interior points so
remember that for later okay so the way
that this argument goes involves a
discussion of what I'll call transverse
intersection in a way that I'll sort of
make up a new definition so I want to
think of a compact path connected
subsets of the plane and I want to say
that this set intersects another set in
fact I'm going to be applying this
notion to a set intersecting a translate
of itself eventually that's why these
two things look the same but i'll say
that this set the red set in the purple
sets intersect transversely if the
following hold the union of these two
sets is path connected and the boundary
has the following property so the
boundary here is connected and the
boundary has points that alternate from
boundary of the red region to boundary
of the purple to boundary of the red to
boundary of the purple and maybe there
are other it alternates in other ways
later but i really only need those first
four alternations between red points
purple points red points purple points
and here's why I'd like to have this
because what I'd like to do is pick a
red point from up here and a red point
down here and draw a path that's
completely contained in the red set pick
a purple point from here
and a purple point from here and draw a
path that's completely contained in the
purple set okay and i want to say these
sets intersect transversely if they have
this property if i can do that so these
pads are linking up and i want to use
that to prove something a little bit
later okay is that clear what I mean all
right and one thing that's kind of
interesting is you can ask what shapes
of subsets of a complex plane have this
transverse intersection property so in
fact if you have a set that's not convex
and this will be key for the discussion
in a few minutes if you have a subset of
the plane that's not convex then there's
a direction that you can shift that you
can translate that set off of itself so
that the original set which is red in
this picture and the image under the
shift which is purple in this picture
have this transverse intersection
property so that's why i drew 62 copies
of the same set there if the set is
convex you won't be able to do that I
can't shift this around to have that
that alternating intersection property
okay so there's something about this
transverse intersection and convexity
that's going to become important for us
a few moments okay so how are we going
to certify use the computer to
rigorously prove that these holes exist
so I mentioned before to you that in
order to prove with the computer that a
limit set is disconnected you can do
rigorously you just have to find some
depth where the blue approximation and
the orange approximation are disjoint
and that certifies it rigorously that
that parameter the set is disconnected
to prove that it's connected is harder
so this is how I'm going to prove that
given a parameter given the limit set
the parameter the limit set is connected
i'm going to use a method which involves
something that we call traps and that
idea of transverse intersection okay
that requires a little lemma so we'll
take our parameter C and we'll draw f of
lambda C and G of lambda see the blue
and the orange piece of the limit set
and suppose that their distance
less than or equal to some positive
number Delta okay so what I'm going to
prove to you is if you have one of these
things called a trap then in fact the
limit set has to be connected because
the distance between the blue and the
orange actually is zero meaning that
these two things will intersect so the
limit set will be connected okay so
let's suppose that the distance is less
than or equal to some positive number
Delta and what I'd like to do is explain
why the existence of something called I
call a trap will prove that the limit
set will be connected ok so this
requires this lemma the distance between
the blue and the orange is less than or
equal to Delta then the Delta over to
neighborhood of the limits set is in
fact path connected it's just a nice to
pology exercise using the ifs it's an
immediate corollary that if you is a
word of length n so when I give you a
word of length and what I'd like you to
think about is a small copy of the limit
set it's been scaled by a factor of C to
the N and what the letters in the word
you tell you are where in the limit said
it lives it's the address ok but it's
just a small copy of the limit set ok so
if you know that the large neighborhood
the neighborhood of the large
neighborhood the Delta over to neighbor
neighborhood of the large limit set is
path connected then it follows by
induction that's a neighborhood of that
size a scaled-down neighborhood Z to the
N times Delta over to of this small copy
of the limit set is also path connected
all right so what's a trap so a trap is
a pair of words of length n the first
word you ends with f the second word V
ends with G that condition is just
saying that you the small copy of the
limits that you get from that word is
blue v the small copy of the limits that
you get from that word is orange ok a
trap is a pair of words of this form so
that this neighborhood of this small
blue copy and this neighborhood of this
small orange copy have this
verse intersection property that I was
telling you about before so this is the
picture to have in mind here is a small
blue copy which turned green here is a
small orange coffee which turned yellow
and these two things intersect
transversely to say that you have a trap
means that you have a small copy coming
from the word you a small copy of the
limit set coming from the word V that
intersect transversely and now I'm going
to conclude that if they intersect
transversely the orange and the blue
then in fact they have to intercept
which means that the limits that has to
be connected okay so the distance the
infimum distance the distance between
the blue copy and the orange copy is
less than or equal to the distance
between the small blue copy and the
small orange copy this follows
immediately from the definition of power
measuring distances because this is a
subset of this this is a subset of this
and then the distance between this small
copy this small blue copy in this small
orange copy is less than or equal to
this quantity here and that comes from
this condition that these two
neighborhoods intersect transversely but
this means then that the distance
between the large blue piece and the
large orange feast has to in fact be 0
because c is less than 1 and modulus
alright so that implies that the limits
that is in fact connected so it implies
that our parameter is inside the
connectedness locusts but in fact this
traps idea this intersection idea
persists under wiggling so you can
wiggle around the limit set moves
continuously and you'll still have this
transverse intersection property so this
gives us an interior point of the
connectedness locus okay so to certify
that we have a parameter which is in the
interior of the set em what we do is we
tell the computer to look for traps it's
going to look for words U and V look for
small copies of the limit set that have
this property
okay so finding traps what do we do so
we'll take a parameter and draw the
limit set draw some approximation of it
using the algorithm I outline for you at
the beginning you take a large disk and
map it forward lots of times you get an
approximation of it if that limit set is
not convex oops then you can find what
I'll call good directions or trap like
balls there are directions where you can
shift the limit set off of itself so
that the original set and its image
under that shift have this transverse
intersection property so I take some
approximation on the computer to my
limit set and I look for good directions
that I can shift this thing and I ask
the computer to remember those good
directions okay so what what the
computer will do is it will find these
good directions and put them in little
balls here there are little open sets
okay and it remembers what they are ok
so then what it does is it searches
through all words U and V of a given
depth and it looks at this displacement
vector to figure out if this
displacement vector is actually parallel
to one of these good directions if it
finds it then it knows then that
actually will give you a trap that will
give you a good direction that will give
you a small copy it will tell you how to
zoom into the limit set so that a little
orange copy and a little blue copy
intersect that way and the displacement
vector between the centers of symmetry
will be parallel to that good direction
is that clear it's converted so that's
what the computer is doing its searching
for for words of a given length that
give you small copies of the limit set
that have been translated off of each
other in these good directions to give
you as transverse intersection property
thereby establishing that the set is
connected and in fact that the parameter
was in the interior of of the
connectedness locus so
here this is what the computer does this
is actually how its coloring that
picture it colors the picture m
according to how hard it is for it to
find traps at a given depth so this is a
picture a subset of the connectedness
locus all these blobs here show you
regions of the interior where there are
traps okay of length 20 this shows you
where their regions of the interior of
traps of length 35 you cover much more
of the set so that's how we're able to
certify that we have interior points of
this set it's how we're able to get our
hands on that so in order to prove that
there is an exotic component that the
set M has holes in it all we have to do
is draw a loop with a computer inside
the connectedness locus and make sure
that we can cover it with these traps
these balls of traps okay because the
computer certifies you have these large
balls you can search you can cover this
path with those with those balls then it
in fact is a subset of the interior so
that will give us that the loop is in
the connectedness locus and then we have
to just prove that there's a parameter
on the inside where the limit set is
disconnected but as I mentioned before
that's easy okay and that gives you a
proof that these holes exist using the
computer all right so in fact the
argument can be promoted we have a
special case where we can get infinitely
many holes using a limiting spiraling
argument which which I won't tell you
about today so we can get infinitely
many of them also again using the
computer to get that the interior is
dense and to establish this conjecture
of Christoph bant there was this
convexity issue that I mentioned so if
the limit set is not convex so what
we're going to do is take a parameter
that we know is inside the connectedness
locus and I'd like to to give you an
argument about why you can approximate
that parameter with interior points with
parameters in the interior of em so you
take this parameter where your limit set
is connected if the limit set is not
convex then you can find these good
directions these trap
vectors where you can shift this thing
off of itself okay so because the
original parameter that you started with
was in the connectedness locus the
intersection of the blue and the orange
is non-empty so there are words U and V
a small copy of the limit set which is
blue a small copy of the limit set which
is orange so there the distance between
their sensors of symmetry is very small
and you wiggle the parameter C around to
make this vector B trap like so you can
find a sequence of traps which approach
which approximates the parameter the
connectedness parameter that you started
with okay so this is just a rough idea
about how to approximate if your limit
set is not convex how to approximate the
parameter in parameter space and the
connectedness locus with a sequence of
interior points in the connectedness
locus okay what if the limit set is
convex well this is a result that goes
back to one of slow max papers figured
out exactly where the limits set is
convex the limit set is convex if and
only if the parameter is of this form in
which case the limit set is some kind of
polygon and that's drawn for you here
here is our set M these red spikes show
you all of these angles here all of
these complex numbers so these red
spikes are precisely where the limit set
is convex so this is where my argument
from the previous slide about taking a
parameter where the limits that is not
convex and approximating that parameter
with interior points in the
connectedness locus will fail note here
the real whiskers are part of this locus
as I said before okay the limit set for
these real whiskers at the line segments
convex all right but we can establish
the theorem that says that the interior
of this set is dense away from the real
axis because the only region that
you have to worry about are the real
acts are the real whiskers here so we
know from Terry Bush's results because
there's this closed annulus that's
contained in this set that the interior
is dense inside here so outside of this
yellow circle was that Terry Boosh
region where the closed annulus is
completely contained in the set em so
the interior is dense there anyway so
the points that remain are the points on
the other side of the yellow circle but
all of the limit sets are convex there
so the argument from the previous slide
will work everywhere except here where
we knew there was a problem anyway ok so
this establishes bands conjecture that
the interior is dense in this set away
from the real axis it's kind of neat
that it sort of boils down to this
question of where the limit set is
convex ok so as I said before it would
be really great to understand why these
components are there and to classify
them so taking our inspiration from what
happens with Z squared plus C you've got
the Mandelbrot set you've got all the
hyperbolic components of the Mandelbrot
set and I mentioned that you can use
finite combinatorial data to label the
hyperbolic components of the Mandelbrot
set to build yourself a roadmap to tell
you how that set is organized how it's
structured to tell you a lot of
information about it it would be great
if we had some kind of combinatorial
invariants or something some piece of
data that told distinguished this this
teeny tiny hole in the set em from this
one that distinguished this whole from
the great lake in the middle this whole
from the smaller one this whole from
this one so we don't have that mechanism
in place yet but when you look in the
dynamical plane it's clear that there is
something to say furthermore from the Z
squared plus C case those hyperbolic
components that data that I mentioned is
dynamical data those components are
dynamically distinguished remember what
we're looking at here it's a little
backwards I'm trying to tell components
in the disconnectedness locus apart
these are components in the Cantor set
locus
logically I'll Cantor sets look the same
so there has to be something else it's
not a topological reason why these
components are there there's some there
in fact isn't even a dynamical reason
because it turns out that the action of
the iterated function system on the
limit set at the limit said as a cantor
set they're all conjugate so there
should be some other reason and I'll say
that it's a geometric reason when I show
you the following slides so it there
should be a geometric reason for these
different components so here this is
this parameter up this parameter up here
if we click here with the computer will
get a cantor set so again this is a
chunky Cantor set it should look more
like a dust of points but it doesn't but
there does seem to be some kind of
combinatorial or geometric information
about how these two pieces fit together
the orange and the blue so you can zoom
in here and you'll see this interlocking
gears picture like this so if there's a
way to quantify it sort of looks like a
zipper there's a way to quantify exactly
what's going on maybe that data can be
used to distinguish this whole from the
other ones if I use the computer and I
clicked here in this teeny tiny hole
right there this picture would change
ever so slightly in the combinatorial
about how these teeth are locked
together would change it would shift
okay so there is some something that's
distinguishing these holes apart and it
appears to be this whatever geometric
phenomenon is causing this locking so
here's a movie I'm going to walk around
the boundary of this hole here and watch
this picture look at how the geometry of
how these things are the blue and the
orange are locked together changes as
you walk around
okay so you can see as you approach
different points on the boundary here
this combinatory exchanges it would be
great to have an understanding of that
so that's something I think that's a
really neat problem okay i do want to
relate this to some other sets that have
shown up there's a neat connection with
this whole discussion two polynomials
and power series so let me just remind
you what our our maps are so we have the
map f and that g all right so if we take
a word of length n in F and G so that's
called w here and we just sort of look
at this as composing to affine
transformations of the plane so I'm
going to get some larger affine
transformation that takes Z to this so
it's going to the scaling factor is
going to be C to the N sees my parameter
and then this is the constant term here
now you can see that these coefficients
are going to be determined by which
letter either f or g you picked and in
fact these coefficients are either going
to be plus 1 or minus 1 coming from this
plus 1 in this minus 1 here so when you
compose these two functions together you
look at a word of length n you'll get
some athlete rants formation of this
form back where the coefficients AI r
plus 1 or minus 1 depending on what
letter you picked at stage I in the word
so for instance the constant term a knot
over there is going to be 1 if your word
ended with an F and minus 1 if it ended
with a G so it will be 1 if your word
gave you an address of a blue point in
the picture it'll be minus 1 if your
word gave you an address with an orange
point in the picture
so in fact using this description
remember the limit set so for given
value of C you have your dynamical
picture here the limits set you can get
by taking some generic point some point
in the plane like Z here and just
mapping it forward under words in fng
and looking at the accumulation set of
the orbit so with this description here
you can see that in fact the limit sets
is going to coincide with values at the
parameter c of power series with
coefficients in plus or minus 1 okay
because you just keep map this you take
some your point you map it forward under
under maps of this form this term
becomes negligible the point you start
it doesn't actually matter so you're
getting values of power series with plus
or minus 1 coefficients at the parameter
C this is kind of a neat description
because it tells us another way to think
about the sets m and M Prime so remember
the set M is the connectedness locus
it's where the blue and the orange
intersect so if I draw my limit set and
the blue and the orange intersect then
obviously there's a point in common what
is the address of that point so this
point is in the limit set because it's
in the orange piece it has a development
it has an address where the constant
term a naught is minus 1 because it has
an address that ended with G but it also
has a development or an address where
the constant term ended with plus 1
because it's a blue point it's in the
intersection so you write down the two
addresses for this one point they're
equal to each other you rearrange that
equation that will give you a power
series in the parameter C with minus 2 0
and minus minus 20 and plus 2
coefficients so the parameter C turns
out to be a root of such a power series
a power series with minus 2 plus 2 and 0
coefficients which of course is just a
root of a power series with minus 1 1
and 0 coefficients so you can completely
characterize the canoe
goodness locusts as a subset the subsets
of D star which consists of roots of
power series with plus or minus 1 and 0
coefficients so are really studying
roots of power series which are just
closures of roots of polynomials so
here's where sort of the neat algebraic
connection comes in similarly that set M
prime which remember consisted of all
parameters for which 0 the center of
symmetry was in the limit set also has a
description in terms of power series so
if you have a parameter for which 0 is
in the limit set that means that 0 is a
root that means that C is a root of a
power series with plus or minus 1
coefficients because you can write 0 as
a series in the parameter C with plus or
minus 1 coefficients so the parameter C
was a root of a power series with plus
or minus 1 coefficients ok and with this
description it's pretty clear that this
set is a subset of this set so thinking
along these lines now you can sort of we
have this ifs description we had these
sets we're studying from them from a
topological point of view but now
there's this connection with roots of
polynomials and in fact this intersects
other areas also maybe you've seen this
picture if you google the beauty of
roots you will see it it's kind of
amazing so Sam derbyshire just decided
one day to plot all the roots of all
polynomials with plus or minus one
coefficients in the same copy of the
complex plane and he did that with
Mathematica and this is his picture he
got up through degree 24 to draw this
picture so based on what I said in the
previous slide this beautiful picture
the set that's inside the disc so here's
the unit circle in this picture the
subset of this picture that is inside
the disc take a topological closure of
it coincides with our set M Prime it's
beautiful fractal which has a
description in terms of a parameter
space coming from dynamics now and that
dynamical description can be used to
won't understand the fractal appearance
of this set of roots ok so this this
sets we're not really looking outside
here remember our parameter space is a
subset of the disk this set is symmetric
with respect to Z maps to 1 over Z of
course because if Z is a root of a
polynomial of plus or minus 1
coefficients and 1 over Z is also ok and
this is this is sort of my favorite
connection I really like very much so
this is a picture from page one of Bill
Thurston's last paper it's called
entropy and dimension one and one thing
that Thurston did in this paper is he
studied he was studying real maps which
take closed and bounded interval to
itself if you'd like you can think about
these as as polynomials and he was
studying a certain class of them this is
a dynamical system he was studying maps
that your post critically finite so what
that means is that every critical point
of the map f has finite forward orbit or
as eventually periodic and he was
interested in the question of what
numbers arise as the entropy of this
dynamical system what numbers do you get
well in fact it's easy to see in the
case of degree 2 if F has degree 2 and
it's post critically finite then there's
a unique critical point and it has
finite forward orbit because the map is
post critically finite so you can take
your domain and range space and chop it
up you can mark it and all of the police
which are images of the forward orbit of
the unique critical points this gives
you a finite set of intervals here gives
you a markov partition actually and you
can encode how these intervals map
around themselves with a matrix this
matrix has
non negative integer entries so there's
a prone frobenius eigenvalue the leading
eigen value of this VAR crafts matrix
lambda is actually equal to e to the
entropy of f ok for this particular
dynamical system so Thurston in fact was
studying these quantities these are
algebraic and he proved that the numbers
that you get that arise this way as
entropy s of interval maps which are
post critically finite are exactly the
set of weak / own numbers it's a certain
kind of algebraic integer but this
picture is a special subset of those so
he was looking just at quadratic
polynomials and he took some large
sample of quadratic polynomials which
are all post critically finite wrapping
the interval to themselves and for every
single one of those quadratic
polynomials that he had on his list he
computed this number in fact the minimal
polynomial for that number and plotted
all of the Galois conjugates all of the
roots of all the entropy polynomials
coming from his sample of post
critically finite quadratic polynomials
he plotted all the roots in the same
copy of the complex plane and that's
what you're looking at here this
beautiful set so in fact there's this
miraculous connection that the Thurston
sets the part of the Thurston set inside
the disc and the roots of polynomials
with plus or minus one coefficients they
have the same topological closure as
proved by giulio Chiodo ok so these sets
coincide the topological closures of
these sets coincide inside the disc and
in fact they are both equal to our set M
Prime coming from the iterated function
system so somehow this distinguished
subset in parameter space for this ifs
sort of knows about this set right here
and enter piece of quadratic polynomials
sort of miraculous
it's supposed to be so it's not
symmetric because of the way that he
drew it we still actually don't know how
picture has a lot of data and was sort
of drawn very which picture no no not
one over Z he's asking I think about
this reflection or this one no no no the
the picture on the left so as I said
what I'm saying I'm talking about just
inside the disc I'm not talking about
outside please note that this set gets
very murky outside here it's we don't
actually know if it's different from
this it probably is but I don't think
very much is known about what that set
is outside the disc okay okay this
picture was drawn by bill by Bill
Thurston I think he knew about all these
connections so here is his in gray is
this set of n trapeze in pink is the set
of roots of polynomials with plus or
minus one coefficients so inside the
disc the gray and the pink coincide by
what I said before Julio's results and
blue is the set of Paula note is a set
of roots of polynomials with plus or
minus 1 and 0 coefficients so from the
point of view of our iterated function
system the blue set is our connectedness
locus inside the disc the pink set is
the set where the parameter the limit
set contains the distinguished point and
that set coincides inside the disc with
this thurston entropy set which is kind
of a miraculous connection and other
people have studied roots of polynomials
from different points of view pune nana
odds let's go studied zeros of
polynomials with 01 coefficients and
again this sort of displays a family
resemblance to the sets that we've seen
so far so it would be neat to kind of
interpret the structure of this set the
topology of this set maybe thinking of
it as a distinguished subset and
parameter space for a dynamical system
like we did with the other one and thank
you for attention
you